The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: It's
time to get started.
Today, we'll complete
our discussion
of nuclear magnetic resonance.
And we started that last time.
And after that, we will talk
about multi-particle states,
the kind of quantum
mechanical states
that you need if your system
has more than one particle.
That will bring us
naturally to the idea
of denser products of
vector spaces, which
is the key mathematical
idea behind operations
such as addition of
angular momentum.
By introducing a little
before, we really
talk about addition
of angular momentum,
the idea of denser
products of vector spaces.
I really hope that
this subject will
look a lot less mysterious
in a couple of weeks
when we will really be
adding angular momentum.
So you will have seen the
main mathematical structures.
And you will know
what you're supposed
to do when you have a formula.
So that should be of some help.
So last time, we
were talking about
nuclear magnetic resonance.
And I described the problem.
Here is a summary of where
more or less we got last time.
We said in the set up for
nuclear magnetic resonance,
we have a large magnetic field,
the longitudinal magnetic field
it's sometimes called,
along the z direction.
In addition to that
longitudinal magnetic field,
there's a rotating magnetic
field in the xy plane.
And it's rotating in the
direction that you see here.
As seen on the xy plane,
it's clockwise on the plane.
In terms of a rotation
around the z direction,
it's negative in the sense
that the positive rotation
around the z plane
would go like this.
And this magnetic
field is rotating
in the other direction.
So I wrote it here.
The magnitude of this radio
frequency component is B1.
And typically, it's
much smaller than B0
in the problems of interest.
Then, as you recall,
the spin Hamiltonian
is always given by this
constant gamma that
relates to the dipole moment of
a particle to its spin angular
momentum B dot S,
the S operator.
And the S operator
has components
Sx, Sy, Sz multiplied by
B. Well, the z component
picks up a z, the x component
Sx, the y component Sy.
And this is your Hamiltonian.
And as we emphasized last
time, this Hamiltonian
is time dependent.
Moreover, at different times,
the Hamiltonians don't commute.
So the HS at time T1, HS at
time T2, they don't commute.
Therefore, any of the formulas
we have for solving problems
like this don't apply.
The only formula that applies
is this time ordered exponential
that we spoke about
that in general
is very difficult to use.
The time ordered exponential
just never quits.
And we're writing
terms, term after term.
And then, you have
to add it all up.
And adding it all
up is difficult.
So most of the time,
it's not a great help.
So what did we say we would do?
We wondered if we could
somehow do quantum mechanics,
or think of quantum mechanics,
in the rotating frame,
in a frame that is rotating with
a magnetic field in such a way
that perhaps in that frame
the physics would simplify.
And physics simplified would
be that the Hamiltonian becomes
time independent.
So we're trying to figure
out, how would the Hamiltonian
look in another frame?
Now, we've not discussed
in general very explicitly
transformations of Hamiltonians
within different frames.
But we can sort of
roughly try to guess
what it would have to do.
So what we said
last time is that we
would imagine that you
have an original system
and no magnetic field,
nothing whatsoever.
So forget about all
that-- no magnetic field.
You put the spin state.
It stays there forever,
doesn't precess.
It doesn't precess because
there's no magnetic field.
Then, you jump into
a rotating frame.
So this was a static
frame, no magnetic field.
And then, you start rotating.
And then, you look at the spins.
And the spins are not moving.
But you say, oh, I'm rotating.
So for me, they seem to be
precessing, in fact precessing
with the angular frequency
that I am rotating.
And therefore, in
my rotating frame,
I would have a
Hamiltonian that I
would call the rotating
Hamiltonian, HR.
And how would it look?
We claim that in fact spin
states in my rotating frame
would have to be
rotating really this way.
Because I'm rotating
with the magnetic field.
So for me, they're rotating
in the positive z direction
with angular frequency omega.
And this would be
the operator that
makes them rotate
exactly that way.
Because if you remember,
an operator here minus
i angle Sz over h
bar, this is the angle
as a function of time.
Omega t, that's how these
operators rotate states.
So this U of t is the
U of t that rotates
states the way I want
them in my rotating frame.
Now, you remember for
time independent systems,
the unitary operator is e
to the minus iht over h bar.
So you identify the
Hamiltonian as omega Sz.
In general, given
a unitary operator,
the Hamiltonian is
obtained this way.
You take the time derivative
of it multiplied by U dagger.
And that's the formula for
the Hamiltonian given the time
evolution operator, something
we did about a couple of weeks
ago.
So that's where we stood-- some
idea about the rotating frame.
So the way we now
make this complete
is to say, well, I'm going to
attempt to do the following.
I'm going to act with U, this U
of t, on this complicated state
that I don't know
how it behaves.
And this I'm going to call
the rotated wave function.
It's a definition.
We're going to use
this operator that
seems to induce a
rotation of the frames
and act it on the
state to find this.
And we're going to hope
that the Schrodinger
equation for this
one is simpler.
So actually, last time, I
actually did a computation
and found what is the
Schrodinger Hamiltonian
for this, psi R. I want to do
it in a slightly different way.
I think it's a little easier
perhaps, or maybe less
familiar but more interesting.
I write this like that-- U of t.
And I say, look,
this state evolves
due to its own Hamiltonian.
U of t is an extra
thing I've put here.
So here is U of t.
But how do I distinguish it?
I put an S for the spin
system, for HS, psi 0.
So psi of t is being evolved
by the Schrodinger Hamiltonian,
the unitary operator
associated to the Hamiltonian
that we want times time of 0.
So this is the total
unitary operator
that evolves this state.
Therefore, I'm going
to say, I'm going
to recover the Hamiltonian
using this formula.
So I will simply say that
the rotating Hamiltonian
is going to be HR is ih bar
dt of this whole thing, U
of t US of t, times its dagger.
Because this is
the general formula
to obtain the
Hamiltonian when you
know the time
evolution operator.
So the dagger of this would
be US dagger U of t dagger.
Now we have to evaluate
this derivative.
It's is not all that bad.
If the time
derivative hits the U,
this one, then U and U
dagger annihilate each other.
So you're left with
U dagger of t here.
So you get ih bar dtU U dagger.
Now, when it acts on this
second one, what do we get?
Well, I'll write it this way.
Plus U of t, because
this will be first.
Then, ih bar dtUS.
And then, you have US dagger,
and then U dagger of t.
Now, this thing is how much?
Well, in this thing is
in fact this Hamiltonian
associated to what we called
U, which is just omega Sz.
So actually, I don't
know if I have-- yeah,
I have this notation here.
I think it's useful-- H of
U, the Hamiltonian associated
to whatever U it is.
So you get a nice
formula-- plus U of t.
This is the Hamiltonian
HS U dagger of t.
So this formula we
derived also last time
by looking at the differential
equations satisfied by psi R.
So it's a nice formula.
If somebody gives you
something like this
and says, here's a
unitary operator,
what is the new Hamiltonian?
The new Hamiltonian is equal to
the transformed old Hamiltonian
plus the Hamiltonian associated
to this time evolution
operator.
It's a nice formula.
Now, more concretely
now, we can see
what this is supposed to be.
So here is the
important crucial step.
Let's see, HR is
supposed to be what?
We now know we're going to
choose U to be this thing.
Therefore, HU is omega Sz hat.
But now we have U
of t, U dagger of t.
So I have plus e to
the minus i omega
tSz over h bar times
the Hamiltonian
that we have over there,
this full Hamiltonian HS.
So what is it?
Minus gamma big parentheses
B0 Sz hat plus B1 cosine omega
tSx minus sine omega
tSy-- like that--
e to the i omega tSz over h bar.
OK, that's supposed to
be our new Hamiltonian.
And unless it simplifies, we
have not gained all that much.
So before simplifying,
are there questions,
anything we've gotten so far?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So U of t is
the unitary operator that
enacts the rotation,
and it's not
corresponding to any
Hamiltonian of the spin?
PROFESSOR: Right, U of t is the
thing that essentially moves us
into the rotating frame.
This is the hope that we have.
Any unitary operator, if
it's what evolves your state,
it corresponds to Hamiltonian.
But that's not
anything a priori to do
with our original Hamiltonian.
It's just another Hamiltonian.
So you choose your U of t
behind some Hamiltonian.
But what you learn is
that the Hamiltonian
for your new system, or
for the new wave function,
will involve that
other Hamiltonian.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: HR equals [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: This is-- yeah.
It's HU.
I think you are probably right.
I should call it
just HU for-- yeah,
it's a bad idea to call it HR.
U, HU, much better-- thank you.
Here, HR is the Hamiltonian
associated to the Schrodinger
equation here.
So the claim behind
this calculation
is that if you calculated
ih bar d dt of psi R of t,
you would find HR psi R of t.
So that's the
calculation I think
we did last time
in which we just
calculated these derivatives.
And you find this answer.
OK, so let's continue
here and see what happens.
Well, I have an Sz and a Sz
similarity transformation here.
But here is Sz.
So that Sz doesn't care.
And it can just go out.
So what do we have?
We have omega minus gamma
B0 Sz hat like that.
Then, the rest would be what?
I can take out the
numbers gamma, the B1.
And then, I have this
exponential-- e to the minus i
omega t Sz hat over h bar.
I'm just having here cosine
omega tSx hat minus sine omega
tSy hat, e to the i
omega tSz hat over h bar.
OK, now there's two
ways to do this.
You have an exponential here
and another exponential.
This is the kind of thing
you've done quite a few times
in different ways.
You could expand exponentials
and just multiply.
Or you can sort of do this
usual formula of e to the AB e
to the minus A for this
term and for this term,
and simplify, and
do many things.
So let's do something different.
When one looks at
this, one could say,
well, here's my problem.
HR-- I know U of t.
I fixed it.
So knowing psi is knowing
psi R. But to know psi R,
I need to know HR.
And HR still looks
very complicated
unless somehow this whole
idea has worked out very well
and this simplifies.
And the hope is
that it simplifies.
Because in the rotating
frame, the field
is not rotating anymore.
So I'll call this M of t.
And I think one
way of doing this,
doing something,
if you're in a rush
and you don't have a formula
sheet or any of those things,
is to just take its derivative,
its time derivative.
Now, if you have a
function of time,
and you don't know what it
is, take its time derivative.
And maybe you'll see a
differential equation
or see something.
So let's take the
d dt of M of t.
OK, so what do we get?
Well, we get the
following-- e to the minus
i omega tSz over h bar.
And I'll put the big
parentheses here.
OK, here I have an object.
This is something I
think you are familiar.
You've been computing these
things for coherence state,
for squeeze state,
and for all that.
So this will certainly
sound familiar.
If you take a time derivative
of this exponential,
it will bring an operator down.
When you take the time
derivative of this operator,
it will bring the operator
down but with a different sign.
And therefore, it will
form the commutator
with the thing like
this in the middle.
So the first thing in this
thing is the commutator
of-- you take the time
derivative of this-- minus i
omega Sz hat over h bar
with the rest of this thing,
with cosine omega tSx
minus sine omega tSy.
Because the first derivative
brings down the minus i omega
this over that.
So I'll actually take the
minus i omega over h bar out.
OK, that's the
first term that you
get from differentiating
this and that.
And then, you have
to differentiate
the term in the middle.
So then, you get minus
omega sine omega tSx
hat minus omega
cosine omega tSy hat.
And now, we can close
the big parentheses
and put the other
exponential like that.
OK, so let's see this.
Sz with Sx is ih bar Sy.
So you get here minus i
omega over h bar, ih bar Sy
cosine omega t.
Because Sz with Sx-- you
should remember that I think.
Otherwise, you'll waste
time. x, y, and z,
when you have Sz
with Sx, you get Sy.
Sx with Sy, you get a z.
And that order helps.
So ih bar this, and
then the other term
would be minus sine omega t.
But now, Sz with Sy is minus
ih bar, so plus ih bar Sx.
OK, I won't copy the other term.
And let's see if it worked out.
Minus i and i is a plus.
The h bar cancels, so plus
omega Sy cosine omega t
minus omega cosine omega tSy.
So this term cancels with this.
And this-- there's an ih bar.
The sign is the same, so
it's a plus omega sine
Sx minus omega sine.
So these two cancel.
And happily, this
whole thing is 0.
So that is the signal
your strategy worked.
Why?
Because M of t looks like it
has lots of time dependence.
But in fact, it has none.
Its derivative is 0.
So if its derivative is
0, you can evaluate it
at any time you want.
Well, the best time to evaluate
it is time equals 0 now.
And you put here 0--
disappears, disappears.
This term disappears.
The whole thing is just
Sx hat, nothing else.
So you may want to do it
the other way by doing
this similarity on
this and on that,
or do it whichever way you want.
But this is good enough.
So we have that this
whole Hamiltonian
has become very simple.
So HR has become--
and I'll copy it here,
I want to make sure-- minus
gamma B0 plus omega Sz
hat minus gamma B1Sx hat.
Very nice Hamiltonian--
just two pieces.
The Sz part of the Hamiltonian
that used to be this
got this extra piece
from the rotation.
That's our omega Sz.
And this piece over
here is all that
is left of the rotating one.
Because in the rotating
frame, the magnetic field
is always along the x-axis
as it was at time equals 0.
So it's a perfectly
nice Hamiltonian.
Let's factor a few things.
Let's remember the
notation that omega 0
is [INAUDIBLE] more
frequency associated to B0.
So I'll write here, this
is equal to minus gamma B0
minus omega over gamma
Sz hat plus B1Sx hat,
which is minus gamma B0 1
minus omega over omega 0 Sz
hat plus B1Sx hat.
So let me look at
what we've done.
First step, I just factor a
gamma here, so nothing else.
And the same gamma went out.
Next step was to
use this equation,
omega 0 equals gamma.
[INAUDIBLE] to eliminate gamma.
So you eliminated gamma by that.
So it's equal to
omega 0 over B0.
So the B0 went out.
And you have 1 minus this thing.
And then, you can
think of this HR
as minus gamma BR times S. In
the usual notation for spin
Hamiltonians, minus
gamma BS, this
is the rotating B, the
so-called rotating B.
But of course, it's not
rotating anymore, happily.
This is just B0 times 1
minus omega over omega 0 Sz
plus B1Sx.
And then, how about our answer?
What is the answer
to this problem?
Well, the answer
is the psi and t.
So psi t is U dagger
times psi R of t.
And U dagger was e to the i
omega tSz over h bar-- omega t,
yeah.
And what is the other U?
Well, the other U associated
to a time evolution
is just e to the
minus iHRt over h bar.
Because HR is time independent.
So this equation that tells us
how psi R evolves is with HR.
HR is time independent.
And therefore,
you'll have here e
to the minus iHR, which is this.
So it becomes plus i gamma
BR dot S over h bar t acting
on the state psi
at time equals 0.
You see, the state
psi R at time equals
0 is the same as the
state psi at time
equals 0 because the unitary
operator is the same.
So let me box this as well.
This is the complete solution
for the problem of the rotating
spins.
So the quantum
mechanical problem
is you've gotten this time
dependent magnetic field.
You want to know
the spin evolution.
Well, the spin evolution
is a little complicated.
It's this whole thing.
And let me just make sure
everything is good here.
Perfect.
Fine.
All right.
Questions.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So you have x
hat, so xc hat and xs hat--
AUDIENCE: BR.
BARTON ZWIEBACH: Oh.
I'm sorry.
It should be BR.
What is the mistake here?
Sorry.
This is terrible.
z hat, x hat.
Thank you.
That's a magnetic field.
Another question.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: This is a
question [INAUDIBLE].
But when we take d
dt of f of t, how
can we take the computation
relation with hu
in that computation?
Why is that the Hamiltonian
that we take in the computation?
BARTON ZWIEBACH: I
don't understand.
When we take the tan
derivative of m of t,
here was m of t
from here to here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
BARTON ZWIEBACH: Why
is this thing here?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, omega sc.
BARTON ZWIEBACH:
It's because when
you take the time
derivative of this--
let me give you a formula
that you should check.
tA minus tA.
d dt of this is equal
to e to the tA, A, B,
e to the minus tA.
That's the formula we used.
It should be all right.
So we have our time
dependent states,
and let's analyze it
and see what it's doing.
Yes?
One more question.
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE] that
we have these magnetic fields,
but somehow, in our
Hamiltonian, it all
boils down to just the spin
operating in the x direction.
BARTON ZWIEBACH: Well, they're
still in the z direction.
AUDIENCE: There's
still the z component,
but the time variant components
in the y and x direction--
BARTON ZWIEBACH:
Has become something
like in the x direction.
Right.
AUDIENCE: It's hard
to say physically,
but what does the system
actually look like?
BARTON ZWIEBACH: That's what
we're going to do right now.
AUDIENCE: All right.
BARTON ZWIEBACH: This formula
is very pleasant to look at.
You say, oh, I'm
very accomplished.
I solved it.
But what does that do?
What does that describe?
That's what we have to do now.
And that's the interesting
part, of course.
So applications always have
B1 much smaller than B0.
This is the longitudinal
component, and that's the case.
Let me describe
for you what this
is doing in case one, omega
much smaller than omega 0.
You see, given B0,
there is an omega
0, the Larmor one over there.
And B0 is very large, so
omega 0 is very large as well.
So omega very slow
is reasonable.
The magnetic field is
rotating much smaller
than whatever rotation this
other magnetic field would
create on the things.
Moreover, if omega is
much smaller than omega 0,
BR is sort of like B0 z
plus B1 x, roughly that.
So what does this do?
Well, this is a magnetic
field mostly along the z-axis.
So here is x, y, z.
This is a magnetic field
that's like this, BR.
Now, this BR, let's assume
also for an assumption that
at t equals 0, the spin of
whatever spin state you have
is up plus z.
So what does this magnetic
field do to the spin?
Well, you have it here.
So this is going
to rotate the spin
states around the axis of BR.
The rotation operator here, this
is minus the angular velocity,
so there's a minus sign
here that you always
must think about.
But forget about
it for a second.
This is rotating
around BR, so this,
supposed to have a spin state
here in the z direction,
is going to start to rotating
in a little cone like that.
It's very close to
the BR, so it's just
going to rotate
around it like that.
And that's what this
part is going to do.
But you say, but that's
not the whole thing.
The whole thing is this as well.
Well, intuitively, this
rotation that this produces
a rotation around
the z-axis, but it's
much slower than this rotation
because this BR field,
its magnitude is
like B0 roughly.
Therefore, it produces
a very fast rotation.
So what you must imagine
is this little spin state
generating this cone here
and rotating a million times
a second, but this
whole thing is still
being rotated by this
exponential around the z-axis.
So this whole cone,
in some sense,
is precessing around the z-axis.
Now, if you want to
know where the spin is
at any instant of time,
you do the following thing.
You say, time equals one second.
So you come here
and say, one second,
a billion turns and a quarter.
It ends up here.
But in one second, this
rotates it by five degrees,
so then it rotates
a little more.
You could do it that way.
That's a good way
to think about it.
But in the approximation,
which is so fast,
basically, this cone has now,
by the second exponential,
been rotated like that.
Now let's do the
case that is really
the important one, the case,
as you could imagine in which
we know some resonance and
omega is set equal to omega 0.
So the physicists know what
omega 0 is for the spins,
and then they make the
radio frequency coincide
with that omega 0.
In that case, you lose
completely the z component here
of this BR.
So BR is going to be B1 x.
And then, here is
what's going to happen.
You have a B1 x here, a B1
over here in the x direction.
The spin state is sitting
at time equals 0 here.
And since normal
exponentials that
do time evolutions
have a minus sign here,
I claim that instead of
rotating the spin around B1,
it's really rotating
it around minus B1.
So the spin will
just go down here.
Rotate, rotate, rotate, rotate.
Now, it's rotating with B1,
which is much smaller than B0.
So it's rotating with
an angular frequency
that is much smaller than omega
0, but it's rotating down here.
And now, what's really
happening is the following.
Let me draw this if I can.
Here it is.
The spin is up, and it
begins to go into the y-axis.
Here is z.
B1 is turning into the y-axis,
so it rotates a little.
So let me ask you, what is the
second exponential going to do?
It's going to rotate it
further, but this time
around the z-axis.
So this one goes down a
little bit in some time,
but then this z exponential,
the other exponential,
is going to rotate
it around the z-axis.
So this is going to go
down a little but rotate.
So actually, what's
going to happen
is that it's going
to do a spiral.
As it begins to go down,
the other one rotates.
It goes down a little,
the other one rotates it.
In fact, this, since B1 is much
smaller than B0 or omega 0,
here now, omega is
equal to omega 0,
so this is rotating around
the z direction with omega 0.
But B1 is much smaller than B0,
so this rotation is very slow.
As it goes down a little,
it's rotating very fast
and fills out the spiral
until it gets down here.
So that's what the poor
spin is doing in this thing.
It's actually of
interest to time
the radio frequency signals,
to time the systems of B1
so that you get it
to go into the plane
so that the spin is
maximally perpendicular
to the original direction.
For that, you
choose omega 1 times
time, which is the Larmor
frequency associated
to B1 times time, to
be equal to pi over 2.
And omega 1, just like any
omega, is gamma B1 pi over 2.
So t is pi over 2 gamma B1.
It's called the half
pulse, something like that.
No, a 90 degree pulse.
That's a normal name for it.
So if you keep the
radio frequency
on for this much time, then the
spin, at the end of the day,
it got to the equator of the
sphere, and B1 has disappeared.
So B1 is gone, BR
is gone, and then
it keeps rotating because there
is the other magnetic field
still, the longitudinal
magnetic field.
One exercise that you
still have in the homework
is to figure out the equation
of the spiral that comes out
of here.
You will find it
sounds complicated,
but it's a couple of lines.
It's very simple,
actually, to do it,
after you think about
it for a second.
That's one thing
you'll have to do.
So this, in fact, is basically
the solution of the problem,
and let's just talk
for a few minutes
about what it's used for.
So this is basically
the technique
that is exactly used for
Magnetic Resonance Imaging,
MRIs.
If you have to say one of
the interesting applications
of quantum mechanics
to technology,
MRIs, Magnetic
Resonance Imaging,
is one of the great ones.
So how does it work?
Well, it's a very useful device.
In fact, it
revolutionized medicine
because it goes much beyond
what you can do with x-rays.
It's very popular.
I imagine a good fraction
of you have had an MRI.
Let's see.
How many people have had
an MRI in their lives?
We're pretty much, I
think, 60% of people here.
So you remember getting
into this cavity?
Well, you've experienced
there a large--
if you worry about
cell phone radiation,
well, there, you
were with two Tesla,
20,000 Gauss, a big, big magnet.
It's big enough that it has to
be cooled with liquid helium
at 3 degrees Kelvin
so you can get
the currents big enough and
the magnetic field big enough.
So they put you into this
cylinder, a solenoid,
and there you go.
And it's not
dangerous unless you
forget some metal or
some device like that.
In fact, it says in
WebMD that if you
have some sort of tattoos,
they used iron ink,
it can burn your skin or you
could have some problems.
Anyway, if you're
claustrophobic,
may have MRIs that are
open air, but they're
less powerful, less
strong magnetic field.
So this is two Tesla, roughly.
And so what happens
is that basically,
this thing just is
trying to figure out
the local
concentration of water.
It begins like that.
The magnetic fields react with
the hydrogen atoms, in fact,
with the protons inside there.
Each proton has a
magnetic dipole moment.
It gets roughly aligned to the
magnetic field, to this B0.
So the protons get
aligned to the B0
that is going in here, B0.
So the proton spin is up there.
In fact, because of
temperature, not all
of your protons in
your body get aligned.
Maybe one in a million does,
but that's high enough.
And then they send
this 90 degree pulse.
So this thing starts
spiraling, and then
it finally goes
into this direction
and it rotates,
rotates like crazy.
Then, as it rotates like
crazy, a rotating dipole moment
is like a generator of
electromagnetic waves.
So it generates an
electromagnetic wave,
and there are detectors all
over that pick up this signal.
The strength of that
signal is proportional
to the concentration of water.
So it gives you an
idea, not to distinguish
solid matter versus soft matter,
but all kinds of liquids.
So it's very, very useful.
You pick a signal over here
and you get it from a receiver,
and it tells you about the
local concentration of water.
And therefore, it allows you to
distinguish different tissues.
Some tissues have lots of water,
some tissues have less water,
so it begins to distinguish
different tissues.
Now, there's two more
things that people do.
This pin is rotating very fast,
but there's a relaxation time.
After it rotates
for a while, there's
a time, T2, is relaxation
of this rotation.
Relaxation time.
And then there's
another time, T1,
which is the time after
this is turned off
that it takes the
spin to go back
again to the original position.
So two times, the
relaxation time
in which you lose
your rotation here
because it's interacting
with other spins.
It's called spin,
spin, relaxation.
And then an interaction with a
whole set of neighboring atoms
that brings it
eventually back up
and aligns it to
the magnetic field.
So you measure two
things, T1 and T2,
and those are very
good clues because you
can put any liquid
in the machine
and measure its T1 and T2.
And then you place a table
of T1's and T2's, and then
if you want to figure
out what kind of thing
you have in your
body, they look it up,
and immediately,
they may know what
are the possible candidates.
In fact, T2 is actually
enough to distinguish
white matter, gray matter,
and fluids in your brain.
Totally different T2's.
T1 is helpful to discuss
all kinds of things as well.
So basically, people have
figured out how to do that.
Finally, one last thing.
When you go into the machine,
it sometimes makes noises.
Big noises.
And those are gradient
magnets that are being moved.
You see, basically, if this
thing would be like that,
you would pick up
a signal and you
wouldn't know where
it comes from.
So what these
people do now-- this
has gotten extremely
sophisticated.
They put a gradient magnet which
changes the value of B0 locally
by increasing it.
For example, the B0 is
not really constant in z,
but it changes.
So the omega 0 of rotation
of the spins changes as well.
So with a sufficiently high
gradient of magnetic field,
they can have
spatial resolution.
If they pick a signal a
little bit higher frequency,
they know it's a little
bit higher up in your body.
So they get resolutions
with these magnets
of about how much?
Very high resolutions.
Half a millimeter.
So at the end of the day,
it's a great machine,
and lots of mathematics
in reconstructing images,
lots of computation, lots
of experimental analysis
of constants, much of
it phenomenological.
It would be hard to
predict those constants,
but you can measure them.
So it's very, very
practical and very nice.
So it's a nice application,
and we'll leave it at that.
Are there any questions?
Not that I know much
more about that.
But it's a junior lab
experiment as well.
So I believe the calculation
is fairly straightforward
and the technology
is just amazing.
It's great.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So about
getting your spin back up
along the z direction,
is that mechanism
the same as when you
relax [INAUDIBLE]?
BARTON ZWIEBACH:
When you relax what?
AUDIENCE: So is the mechanism
for getting your spin back
along the z
direction to find T1,
is that the same
mechanism as when
you do all of this [INAUDIBLE]?
BARTON ZWIEBACH: No.
It's sort of a
different mechanism.
We don't analyze it.
It's not being driven by
Schrodinger time evolution.
All these relaxations are
more complicated phenomena.
In fact, if you maintain
the magnetic field,
this is supposed to go
on forever and never stop
rotating.
But due to interactions
with other things,
it's sort of stops
rotating at some stage,
and then eventually, many
of them also go back up.
So these are not easily
calculable things
within our analysis.
These are
phenomenological constants
that need to be measured
or done by experiment.
So last part of today's lecture
is multi-particle states
and tensor products.
Let's get on with that.
Let's see we have there.
So multi-particle states
and tensor products.
The idea is the following.
You have a system with
more than one particle.
Let's talk two particles.
It won't matter at this
moment whether they're
distinguishable,
not distinguishable.
Those are things
that come later,
and we will probably not discuss
much of that in this semester.
This will be more in 806.
But let's consider if
we have particle one,
and we'll keep the
possibility that this
is completely
distinguishable, in fact.
Particle one.
Its quantum mechanics is
described by a complex vector
space, v. And you have
some operators, T1, T2.
Particle two,
complex vector space,
w, and the operators,
S1, S2, all that.
You see, the list of
operators is something
that you are already
familiar with.
Quantum mechanics operators
can include momentum, position,
if it's three dimensional,
three positions, three momenta,
angular momentum, spin,
Hamiltonians, all those things,
and those exist
for both particles.
So the question is, how do we
describe the composite system,
the system of the
two particles that
exist at the same time, that
possibly could interact even
with each other?
So we need a description
of these two things.
Well, a description
of particle one
is described by some vector,
v, in the vector space.
Description of particle two is
some state, some vector omega,
in the vector space w.
So we imagine that
it's a reasonable thing
to give you those two
vectors and say, look,
that's what particle
one is doing,
that's what particle two is
doing, and that is correct.
It's a bit more subtle than
that, as we'll see now,
but we could list v
and list w, and this
is the information
about each particle.
And this is, in some ways,
too naive, as we will see.
It has the right idea, but
the amazing possibilities
that can take place when
you have these two particles
are not quite reflected
on that thing yet.
So to make this idea clearer,
we'll use a notation.
So I will say that I
will encode these things
and I will write them
as v tensor product w.
It's reflecting that we're going
to do something more than just
view this as the possibility.
You have a system.
You know what the
particle one is doing,
you know what the second
particle is doing.
List those two, that's
all that can happen.
Not quite true.
So let's put it like that, and
this will be the information.
BARTON ZWIEBACH:
I'm not multiplying
this in any obvious way.
It's not that I'm supposed
to multiply and do
a calculation here.
I'm just putting the
two pieces of data
but putting this
curly ball here as
to say that it's
the two together,
and we'll have some ways of
dealing with this object.
And this will be
said to be an element
of a new, complex vector
space, v tensor w.
So what we are saying here,
with v belonging to v and w
belonging to w, this
thing belongs to v plus w.
Tensor product of
the vector spaces.
At this moment, this
is a little funny,
but let me ask you
some things about it.
We have v w.
So this is an element
of that space.
I put a vector of the
first vector space here
and I put a vector of
the second vector space,
and this will be a vector here.
I'm not saying it's the
most general vector there,
or how we operate with them,
but it's a vector there.
Now, you say, look,
when I had states,
you had states plus minus, you
put constants in front of them.
So I'll put a constant in
front of this v, alpha.
Well, is this something related?
We had this vector that was a
vector in the tensor product.
How is this vector
related to this vector?
Well, unless you declare that
these things are somewhat
related, this object is
going to be very, very large
because if this vector has
nothing to do with this,
this is going to be
yet another vector
linearly independent with this.
So it's, again, your choice
what you're going to declare.
If you will be constructing
what is called a direct product,
not a tensor product,
and that's apologies
to [? Shanker. ?] He uses the
word "direct products" wrong
mathematically.
Mathematicians don't call
this a direct product.
Direct product is
something in which
this has nothing
to do with this.
But in physics, you're
thinking of the amplitude
to have a first particle
doing that, and suddenly,
that amplitude becomes twice
as big and this other one
doesn't change.
Well, the amplitude
defining this one here
and that one there has
become twice as big
just because this one is
twice more likely to be here
and that's the same.
So we're going to say that
this is the same as that.
The alpha can go out
and it's the same thing,
and it's also the same
thing as v tensor alpha w.
So numbers go out,
and they don't go out
with a complex conjugate.
They go out just like that.
So that's one thing
we declare that
will happen with these
things, and that's
a property that we impose.
It's what is usually
understood to take place
in tensor products.
Now, if this is a
vector in this space,
then if, for example,
v1 is a vector
and v2 cross w2 is a
vector in v cross w,
then this is supposed to
be a linear vector space.
So it should be true that alpha
v1 omega 1 plus beta v2 omega 2
also belongs to
this vector space.
And suddenly, you see why
this was a little too naive.
If you tell me, this is
what particle one is doing
and this is what particle
is doing, end of story,
this list, well,
quantum mechanics
seems to say that there's
more interesting possibilities
in which the state is
a superposition now
in which first particle
is doing this, which
may be a superposition
itself, and this one
is doing this, plus first
particle is doing that
and second particle
is doing that.
So it's not enough to say to
the state of two particles,
say, you just need to
know the state of one,
state of the other,
list the two.
That is a possible
state of the system,
but it's not the most general.
The most general
is a superposition
in which particle
one does something,
particle two does something,
plus another possibility,
particle one is
doing something else,
particle two is
doing another thing.
This is the origin of this
famous idea of entanglement,
as we will see you next time.
But let's just continue here.
These particles,
roughly speaking,
seem to be entangled,
in which you
can't say what particle one
is doing without knowing what
particle two is doing
and things like that.
So something new has happened
by taking this idea slowly
and figuring out
what's going on,
but we need yet one
more thing to cut down
this tensor product.
This tensor product is
still a little bigger
than what you may want it to
be in the following sense.
Suppose you have
v1 plus v2, which
is another vector,
tensor w, another vector.
Unless you tell
me what this is, I
don't know that this is
actually v1 plus v2 unless you
declare it.
This is just another
vector here and that.
Why should that
be equal to this?
Well, it's the way you feel
about quantum mechanics.
That's how you should think
of the composite system.
If the first state can be
either of two possibilities
while the other one
is not, well it's
a superposition in which, yes,
the first state is doing this
and the first state
is doing something
different with the
second doing the same.
So this is part of also an
axiom of the tensor product.
Whenever you have
tensor products,
you will simplify in that way.
It looks almost trivial,
but it's certainly
something that has to be stated.
If you had a direct product,
you form a vector space
by just putting first
vector, second vector,
and you don't explain anything.
This would not be true.
So similarly, we'll also have v1
w1 plus w2 equals v1 w1 plus v1
w2.
So these are our
last operations.
So with these two
operations, we've
defined completely how to
calculate with this two
particle Hilbert space, and
how to define the states.
Let me add some intuition to
this by stating the following.
So what is this
space, v tensor w,
is the space spanned
by things like this.
So with these rules,
here comes the thing
that puts it all, in
a sense, together.
If e1 up to en is a basis
for v, and f1 up to fm
is a basis for w, this set
of things, ei tensor fj,
and how many of them are there?
There are n of this
and m of those.
This for i from 1 up
to n, j from 1 up to m,
form a basis for v tensor w.
So basically, if you have a
four dimensional vector space
v and a 10 dimensional
vector space w,
v cross w is 40 dimensional.
You multiply the dimensions.
You don't sum them.
In the tensor product,
the dimensions multiply.
You see, the elements
of this tensor product
was one vector here,
one vector there.
So it behooves you that you
would expect that, well, you
can get all vectors that can
sit here with all the ei's, all
the vectors here,
but only if you
have these rules of
superposition and linearity.
So this is the whole
basis of the vector space.
And dimension of
v cross w would be
equal to the dimension of
v times the dimension of w.
Questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So for the
first box thing up there,
so v and w are two
different vector spaces.
Let's say that they're vector
spaces over different fields.
How do you know that--
BARTON ZWIEBACH: Oh no.
Different fields, no.
Both are over complex numbers.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
They're both complex.
BARTON ZWIEBACH: Both spaces
are complex vector spaces.
Did I say it?
Complex vector space,
complex vector space.
Then v cross w is an element
of a new complex vector space.
So yes, everybody's
complex here.
Let me continue a
little more because we
need to get a little further.
I would like to get a
little further here today.
We still have about 10 minutes.
These are really,
in some ways simple
but in some ways
very subtle ideas.
I hope you appreciate it.
At some moments, you
think, this is obvious.
It's ridiculous.
It's taking too
long to explain it.
At some point, you step back
and say, I'm now confused.
What does that mean?
It is subtle.
So let's see now what happens.
We need to do
operators on v cross w.
So suppose T is an operator in
v, and s is an operator in w.
So we call them like that, T
operators and the S operator
on w.
So here it is.
We define an s
tensor T that will
be an operator on the
tensor product, v cross w.
Let's see how it is.
So if this is an operator
on the tensor product,
it should know how to
act on v any element.
In any basic element or
element of this form,
since all the elements can
be written as superposition
of these things, if this
is a linear operator
and I define it acting
on this, we've got it.
Now, what I'm going to
write in the right hand side
is a matter of common sense.
It's a definition, but
it's hardly possible
to have any other definition
than what I'm going to do.
Lights.
Main screen, window shades.
Oh, lights here.
There we go.
Well, you know, I got the
order wrong here, T cross S.
And the only thing
you could do is
if T, you know how it acts
on v. Well, let it act on v.
And it will be a vector in
v, and you know how S acts
on omega, so let
it act on omega,
and that's the definition.
Not that complicated,
really, in a sense.
Each operator acts on its
thing, so you just let it act.
Whoever has to act, acts
wherever it can do it.
And it's linear operator, and
if you act on more things,
it will be linear.
It will all be fine here.
Now, this is a fine operator.
Now, the operators that are
a little more surprising,
perhaps, at first sight
are the following.
Suppose you have an operator,
T1, that is an operator on v,
and you want it to act
on the tensor product.
You say, well, I need
another operator.
This acts on v. I need another
operator attached on the tensor
product, but you don't give
me one, so what am I to do?
So this is what is called
upgrading an operator that
acts on one vector space
to an operator that
acts on the whole thing
because you need everything
to act now on the
tensor product.
So what you do is the following.
You let the operator
become T1 that acts on v,
and you put tensor product
with the identity operator.
This is more or less
what you would imagine.
You have now an operator that
belongs to the linear operators
on the tensor product,
but it's the operator
you got times that.
If you had an operator,
S1, belonging to L of w,
it would go into 1 times S1.
Now I ask you the question,
do these operators commute?
Strange question, but it's
a fundamental question.
It's really the basis of most
of your intuition about two
particle systems.
Well, let's see if they commute.
You have T1 tensor 1
multiplied by 1 tensor S1.
It's going to act on v tensor w.
Or you have it in the
other order, 1 S1 T1 1.
Well, when it acts, the first
part, it gives me T1 tensor 1,
but now acting on this,
this is v tensor Sw.
And then when I
act on this one, I
get now T1 on v tensor S1 of w.
And when I act here, the first
step, it gives me a T1 on v,
and the second gives
me the S1 on w,
so it gives me the same thing.
T1 on v, S1 on w.
So these two operators,
because they originated,
they've operators of the
first particle, operator
of the second particle, they
can act on the whole system,
but they still commute.
They don't know
about each other,
and the communication
now is the calculation
which you just have seen.
What this is a good
example of this thing
is that when you try to
write the Hamiltonian
of the whole system, H
total, you would say,
oh, it's the Hamiltonian
of the first system,
tensor 1, plus 1
tensor the Hamiltonian
of the second system.
Time for an example.
So the example is a famous one,
and this is a great example
because it's at the basis of
combining angular momentum.
So it's an example you're going
to see now and see many times.
Two spin one 1/2 particles.
The first partoc;e has a
state plus and a state minus
for the first article.
The second particle has a
state plus and a state minus.
So how do we form
the tensor product?
Well, we say,
these are our basis
states for the
first Hilbert space,
the basis states for the
second Hilbert space.
We're supposed to take
the product state.
So our tensor product is going
to be spanned, so two spins.
The tensor vector
space is spanned
by a vector in the first
times a vector in the second,
the basis vectors.
You could have plus in 1,
minus in 2, minus in 1,
plus in 2, and minus
in 1, minus in 2.
So two spin states form a
four-dimensional complex vector
space.
That's how you describe them,
with those little products.
And the most general
state is the following.
Most general state
is a psi, which
is alpha plus plus-- you could
put 1 and 2-- plus here's alpha
1, alpha 2, plus, minus,
plus alpha 3 minus, plus,
plus alpha 4 minus, minus.
Let's do just one simple
computation, be done for today.
I want you to try
to figure out what
is the result of acting with
a total z component of angular
momentum on this state,
whatever that means.
Total z component
of angular momentum.
So naively speaking, the total
z component of angular momentum
would be the z component
of angular momentum
of the first particle plus
the z component of the angular
momentum of the second
particle, but you
know that's not the
way we should write it.
So how is it really?
It should be Sz of the first
particle tensor product with 1
plus 1 tensor product with
Sz of the second particle.
You can say 2 or 1 here.
This is really what it is.
You see, how do we upgrade an
operator in the first Hilbert
space to an operator
on the tensor product?
You just let it act
on the first state
but do nothing on the second.
So summing the two
angular momenta really
means constructing this new
operator in the new, larger,
more extended space in
which it acts in this way.
So let's just calculate what
that is and we'll stop there.
Let's see.
For example, we'll have
the first term, Sz 1
tensor 1 acting on psi
on the whole state.
Well, it acts on the
first term, alpha 1.
Now, this operator is
supposed to act on this thing,
so this acts on that
and that acts on that.
So you get-- I'll write
this whole thing-- Sz
hat on plus tensor plus
for the first term.
This term just acted on that.
We can act with
the second one now.
Well, I was putting the first,
so let me leave the first.
Let's do the second
term, plus alpha 2.
It still acts on the first
only, Sz hat plus tensor
minus plus alpha 2 Sz hat on
minus tensor plus, plus alpha
4 Sz hat on minus tensor minus.
Now, what is this?
Well, this thing is h
bar over 2 times plus,
and the number, of course,
goes out of the tensor product.
You don't worry about that.
There's h bar over 2 everywhere.
Alpha 1 plus, plus.
Here the same, another plus,
so plus alpha 2 plus, minus.
And here is minus, so
minus alpha 3 minus,
plus, minus alpha 4,
also minus, minus, minus.
So that's what it is.
If I do the other one, you
could do it with me now quickly.
1 tensor Sz 2 on psi.
Once you get accustomed,
these are pretty direct.
So I have to act with
Sz hat on these ones,
so I just act on the second
one, on the second state.
So I get h bar over 2.
For the first one,
you get a plus,
because it's acting
on this thing,
so you get alpha 1 plus, plus.
For the second one,
however, you get a minus
because it's the second
operator, so minus alpha
2 plus, minus.
For the third one,
it's a plus, so you
get a plus alpha 3 minus, plus.
And for the last
one, it's a minus,
so you get minus
alpha 4 minus, minus.
So when you add them
together, these two pieces,
it's the total, Sz total,
acting on the state,
and what did you get?
You get h bar, this one's
at, alpha plus, plus alpha 1.
These two cancel,
these two cancel.
Minus alpha 4 minus, minus.
That's the whole action
of Sz on this thing.
And if you wanted to have a
state with total Sz equals 0,
then you would have to put
alpha 1 and alpha 4 to 0.
You will, if you
want, at some stage,
calculate, maybe in recitation,
how much is Sy at this state
and how much is
Sx at this state,
and try to figure
out if there is
a state whose total spin
angular momentum is 0.
It's just a
calculation like this.
So next week, we'll
continue with this
and with teleportation
and Bell inequalities.